en 1890 mathématicien giuseppe p and o
prouvost l'un des théorèmes les plus
stupéfiants de l'histoire ce théorème
dit qu'il est possible de colorier
parfaitement un carré avec un crayon
infiniment fin un client qui ne colle
aux ricains point mathématiques à la
fois
ou dit autrement il existe ne courbent
mathématique appelé courbe de p and o
qui colorie tous les points du carré
pour construire l'un des objets les plus
mystérieux des mathématiques et anne ou
partie d'une tentative désespérément
rater cette tentative c'est la courbe à
l'écran très clairement il ne coloris
pas du tout où le carré mais pernaut
pensa qu'il s'agissait d'une bonne base
appelons le le motif 0 il copiaco l'a
ensuite neuf fois le motif euros pour
recouvrir plus d espace puis il tourna à
certains de ces motifs de sorte que l'on
puisse désormais lié boutabout les neuf
copie d'une motif c'est mieux mais on
est encore très très très loin d'avoir
colorier tanger pour du carré p and o se
rendit compte que comme sa tentative
initiale
cette seconde tentative commence en bas
à gauche et finit en haut à droite
du coup cette fois c'est ce motif un
qu'il copie colle neuf fois comme
précédemment il tourne ceux qui sont en
haut en bas à gauche et à droite puis
juin les boues pour faire de tout ça un
tracé de coloriage encore une fois on
obtient un tracé que je vais appeler le
motif 2 2 p and o qui commence en bas à
gauche et qui finit en haut à droite
si bien que l'on va pouvoir répéter
notre opération de démultiplication du
motif pour obtenir un motif 3 et ainsi
de suite
alors bien entendu à l'instar des motifs
0 1 2 ou 3 chaque motif n ne collorec
une fraction infime des points du carré
mais comme vous vous y attendez sans
doute
l'astuce génial de p and o était de
considérer le motif infinie c'est à dire
le motif que l'on obtient après une
infinité de motifs ce motif infinie
c'est ce qu'on appelle la courbe de p
and o alors dit comme ça on pourrait
croire que la courbe de piano à quelque
chose de mal défini et même qui est
assez absurde de considérer qu il
east un motif infinie heureusement à
l'époque de p and o la rigueur de
bolzano byers tracé kantor dont on a
déjà parlé dans les épisodes 7 et 9
permirent de mieux comprendre comment
considérer la limite des motifs de p and
o ceci étant dit plutôt qui étudié la
courbe de piano je vous propose
d'étudier celle de hilbert tu envoies
cours de l'hiver c'est la même idée un
concours de piano en fait liberté tu es
un gros coup peter mais il a quand même
su simplifier les idées de p and o
plutôt que de faire neuf copie à chaque
fois ils n'en demandent que quatre et ça
permet un peu de simplifier le
raisonnement le motif 02 liberté
commence en bas à gauche et fini en bas
à droite
grâce à cette astuce illberg pu
construire le motif 1 avec uniquement
quatre copies du motif 0 en tournant les
deux motifs en bas en relais ensuite les
motifs il obtient alors un motif qui
encore une fois comment sont bas à
gauche et fini en bas à droite
du coup comme pour les motifs de p and o
on peut répéter cette construction pour
construire le motif 3 2 ils berthe et
ainsi de suite à l'infini on obtient
alors la cour de pertes
du coup le motif n de liberté est un
quart et deux par deux motifs elle
moisins et chaque motif elle - est un
carré de parts de deux boutiques n - 2
et ainsi de suite
en fait on voit que le motif andy
hilbert fait un quadrillage de puissance
n par deux puissants scène de motifs 0
de liberté
revenons-en maintenant aux motifs 0day
verte on peut choisir la vitesse à
laquelle on parcourt son motif de sorte
que l'on passe un quart de notre temps
dans le carré en bas à gauche puis un
quart de temps en haut à gauche puis un
quart en à droite et enfin le dernier
quart de temps en bas à droite
passons maintenant aux motifs 1 là
encore on peut adapter notre vitesse de
coloriage de sorte que le temps que l'on
passe dans chacun des carrés du
quadrillage 4 par 4 soit le même et
ainsi de suite pour les motifs supérieur
n'a donc défini la vitesse de coloriage
pour chaque motif n
merci va être génial c'est que la
vitesse de collage du motif n va être
compatible avec la vitesse de coloriage
et émotif précédent en effet peu importe
le motif n qu'il considère la vitesse à
laquelle on parcourt le motif n est
toujours tel que le premier quart du
temps en soit en train de colorier le
carré en bas à gauche puis le deuxième
quart du temps en coloris celui en haut
à gauche
puis le troisième quart du temps on
colorie celui en haut à droite et enfin
le dernier quart de temps est passé dans
le carré en bas à droite et cette
propriété reste vrai à l'infini lorsque
l'on coloris le motif infinie on sera en
train de colorier le carré en bas à
gauche pendant le premier quart du temps
de même le premier 16e de temps est
passé dans le carré en bas à gauche et
le premier 64e de temps lui est passé
dans le tout petit gars et en babouches
et ça ça veut dire que si je colorie la
courbe de gilberte que je considère un
instant t de coloriage de la courbe de
liberté en fonction des décimales en
base de thé je saurai exactement quel
point du quart et je serai en train de
colorier à ce moment donné où là je sens
qu'un petit crash corse sur les nombres
à virgule en base de nécessaire
en base de on a le droit d'utiliser que
deux chiffres le 1 et le zéro tout
nombre entre 0 et 1
s'écrie du coup forcément 0,1 une suite
2 0 et 2 hors et alors c'est comme ça
que vos ordinateurs et smartphones
comptent
prenons un exemple considérons le nombre
0,1 0 0 1 0 1 1 18
le premier chiffres après la virgule est
1 1 ça veut dire que ce nombre est plus
proche de 1 que 2 0 ou autrement dit les
plus grands que 1,2 me puis le chiffre
suivant est 1 0 et ça ça veut dire qu'on
est plus proche de 1/2 que 2 1 ou
autrement dit le nombre est plus petit
que trois quarts on a ensuite 0 ce qui
veut dire qu'on veut être à gauche de la
séparation à mi chemin entre un 2003
gars
autrement dit on va se retrouver entre
un demi et 5 8e et ainsi le sultan bien
je prétends que si on me donne les
deuxièmes premières décimales d'un
instant t je suis capable de savoir
exactement quel carré du quadrillage de
la puissance n par de puissants scène on
est en train de colorier à l'instant t
vous prenons l'exemple de thé égale 0,1
0 0 1 0 1 1
les deux premières décimales me disent
que t'es est entre deux carrés trois
quarts du coup je sais qu à l'instant t
je suis en train de colorier le carré en
haut à droite puis les quatre premières
décimales me disent que t'es est entre
9/16 et 10 16e
du coup je serai en train de colorier le
carré tout en haut au milieu droite du
quadrillage 4 par 4 et ainsi de suite
en fait à l'infini je serais même
infiniment précises sur la localisation
du point
je suis en train de colorier à l'instant
t et ça ça devrait vous convaincre qu'à
chaque instant la courbe de gilberte
coloris un et un seul point
autrement dit la courbe de liberté bien
défini et qui plus est on sent que le
coloriage par la courbe de liberté du
carré se fait de façon continue c'est à
dire qu'on pourra suivre la cour de
liberté avec un crayon infiniment enfin
sans jamais lever le crayon mais pour ça
je laisse les post bac parmi vous
essayez de le démontrer mais le truc fou
avec la courbe de l'île verte et la
courbe de bienne où ce n'est pas le fait
que l'on puisse définir des motifs
infinie c'est surtout que ces motifs
infinie coloris bel et bien tous les
points du cac prenons n'importe quel
point du carré ce point est forcément
dans l'un des carrés du quadrillage de
part de notre cas c'est celui en bas à
droite du coup l'instant t où je
passerai par ce point sera forcément
entre trois quarts et 4/4 ou autrement
dit l'écriture décimale de thé commence
par 0,1 1
ensuite dans le quadrillage quatre par
quatre il est en haut à droite et du
carré que l'on vient de définir pour les
instantes et où on passe par ce carré là
sont les instantes et entre 12/16 et
13/16 ça veut dire que l'écriture
décimales en base 2,2 t commence par 0,1
1,00 à l'infini en suivant ce procédé on
construit donc un nombre tai chi est
égal dans notre cas à 0,1 1 000 1 et
ainsi de suite
eh bien on peut vérifier qu'à cet
instant t précis on est effectivement en
train de colorier le point que j'avais
choisi de façon arbitraire dans le carré
on vient de prouver que si on prend
n'importe quel point du carré alors on
peut déterminer un instant t ou on est
en train de colorier exactement ce point
du carré et ça ça montre bien que tout
point du carré et colorié un instant ou
un autre par la cour de gilberte et
comme vous pouvez l'imaginer tout ce que
l'on vient de prouver pour le corps
d'huile berthe peut se prouver de façon
similaire pour la courbe de p and o même
si pour la cours de piano c'est plus
utile de raisonner en base 3 ou base 9
avant dernière chose on peut généraliser
la courbe de gilberte
pour la prolonger sous forme de spirale
et colorié incident non seulement tous
les points du carré mais aussi tous les
points du plan
c'est trop fou et on peut même faire des
généralisations de ce procédé pour
colorier tous les points de l'espace
vert faire une courbe qui remplit
l'espace 3d et même des espaces de
dimension m6 ont enfin dernière chose
vous pensez peut-être vous habituer mais
c'est toujours surprenant cette courbe
de albert de cet objet mathématique ce
délire de mathématiciens à des
applications totalement inattendue et
pas du tout prévu notamment en
informatique pour par exemple encoder
des images on peut encoder pixel par
pixel et l'ordre dans laquelle on
parcours épique c'est plutôt que suivre
un serpent ainsi beaucoup plus
intelligent de lister les pixels selon
l'ordre donné par la courbe de y perdre
notamment parce que si on veut faire des
mises à l'échelle après on peut utiliser
les propriétés de similarités d'échelle
de la corde et berthe 1 comme on l'a vu
chaque motif n + 1 des cours de l'hiver
trop s'en prennent pas mal au motif n
et ça ça veut dire qu'on va voir des
bonnes propriétés de notre façon de
représenter une image si au lieu de
lister les pixels ligne par ligne
on les listes selon l'ordre donné par la
cour de l'île verte
bref j'ai l'impression de le répéter à
chaque épisode mais je trouve ça quand
même super cool a répété l'infini c'est
super dire autant la 1ère fois on a
parlé de l'analyse de foyers des sinus
et des caussinus volante un drop me
signale que du mal à visualiser ce que
je faisais avec mes mains quand je
disais que le signe s'était étalée
infiniment et je suis désolé j'aurais dû
mettre des images
donc voici quelques images d'un sinus
vous voyez que le sinus ne faiblit pas à
l'infini prend toujours ces mêmes
oscillations à vous imaginer que si
c'est quelqu'un qui sautent selon ces
oscillations il ne faiblit pas l'infini
ne va jamais se calmer ça veut dire
qu'il ne peut pas être écrit comme une
intégrale de foyers en particulier on ne
peut pas vraiment prendre l'a
transformée de fourier du sinus inverse
si on regarde la courbe du sinus
cardinal le sinus cardinals et le sinus
2 x 10
paris x on voit que c'est un truc qui va
se calmer à l'infini ce calme est
d'ailleurs assez doucement à l'infini
donc avoir une transformée de fourier du
sinus cardinal mais ça peut être ça va
pas avoir toutes les très bonnes
propriétés de dérive habilité tout ça
par opposition si je prends une courbe
gaussienne du congo siagne bon ça aussi
il pas motivé par insinue south park
aussi 10 pour faire en sorte que ce
récit lagos yen qui oscille comme cela
c'est un objet ultra important fait dans
la physique théorique notamment quand on
essaie de décrire un photon en fait un
photon ça va être souvent un paquet de
monde et ben typiquement la négocier une
courbe qui est très très très gentil
dans ce sens où elle va vraiment
disparaître très très rapidement à
l'infini ou quasiment plus rien avoir à
l'infini et ça ça veut dire qu'elle se
prête très bien à l'analyse de fous
rires
bob marlène fait remarquer qu'il ya
beaucoup de liens entre l'analyse de
fourier et la musique est en effet une
superbe vidéo de sciences et oriente son
ami jean yves gentil où il parle de ce
lien profond entre l'analyse de fourier
la mécanique quantique et la musique
notamment
comme le dit bob marley d'ailleurs on
peut utiliser audacity l'office et lille
europe ont calculé des transformée de
fourier et c'est ce que fait d'ailleurs
de vide dans sa vidéo les plusieurs
années j'avais aussi fait une vidéo en
moitié en anglais sur trois quarts
anglais sur physique sauvé est un sale
gosse qui sont au fait des trucs pour
faire un massage de tête et en fait j'ai
vu en faisant joujou avec sa douce en
découle que illustré très bien un
phénomène qu'on appelle la résonance la
résonance c'est un outil ultra utile si
vous veut calculer des transformée de
fourier
en fait nos s'ils utilisent des
phénomènes de résonance pour calculer la
transformée de fourier du son que nos
oreilles entende et c'est pour ça que
quand on entende quelqu'un parler on
entend très bien ça boit on entend par
un un brouhaha avec le volume on entend
vraiment des notes des fréquences de son
disque
autrement dit nos oreilles effectué des
transformée de fourier à tout instant sa
septième mais il ya trop la classe
et ça fait dire à bob marley qu'il
trouve ça surprenant au moins que j'ai
du mal vraiment avec l'analyse de
feuilles je trouve ça vraiment où un
monde difficile alors que ça a l'air
super concret ce que je dirais c'est que
c'est pas parce qu'on est familier parce
qu'on voit quelque chose au quotidien
qu'on ne comprend vraiment même offert à
ses gars fin il ya pas mal de trucs que
l'on rencontre au quotidien qui sont en
fait incroyablement difficile à
comprendre et villa notamment cédric
villani donne souvent l'exemple du poil
de la transition de phase donc on voit
souvent des glaçons fondre par exemple
quand on les met dans le pastis et bien
le changement d'état le passage de
solide liquide est quelque chose que
tout casser tagliani dire régulièrement
qu'il s'agisse d'une question qui n'est
vraiment pas comprise mathématiquement
et que c'est vraiment un problème
mathématique difficile de comprendre
comment cette transition de phase
intervient car je connais pas très bien
le domaine mais je mettrais facilement
plusieurs pièces à parier que c'est
intimement liée à de l'analyse de forêt
etienne didot qui a sans doute revu
toute ma série sur la relativité
générale lui pose la question des
applications de la géométrie euclidienne
à la vie réelle puisque l'impression
kilométrique la vreg remettra it à son
ennemi qui viennent donc à ce qu'est la
géométrie euclidienne existe vraiment
dans notre monde et l'avionneur et pense
à petit peu saugrenue mais
incroyablement folle je trouve à mon
sens à cette remarque
oui la géométrie euclidienne est très
très très utile dans plein de domaines
de la physique et des mathématiques et
de l'informatique
tout ce que vous voulez mais je dirais
même que la géométrie euclidienne est
particulièrement utile en analyse de
fourier en fait faire de l'analyse de
fourier c'est travailler dans un espace
leclerc et en fait même beaucoup plus
facile
on sent ce qu'a dû comprendre l'analyse
aux fourriers quand on essaie de l'art
et de raisonner sur l'analyse de fourier
d'un point de vue purement géométriques
d'un point de vue de géométrie
euclidienne notamment en fait faire un
phénomène de résonance et d'été fait
juste une fréquence
ça correspond à ce qu'on appelle une
projection orthogonale et notamment pour
prouver les trucs de production
orthogonale qu'on peut utiliser le fait
que le carré d'une hypothèse est égale à
la somme des carrés des côtés opposés
si et seulement si il ya un angle droit
entre les côtés opposés c'est le graal
de pythagore et le théorème de pythagore
et en fait super utile en analyse de
fouet et même une généralisation de
l'analyse de fourier et de la joie mais
truc lydienne kan appelle les espaces de
hibernent dans lequel encore une fois on
est une version du théorème de pythagore
et tout ça c'est au coeur de la
mécanique quantique si vous voulez
expliquer pourquoi les ex tron reste
autour des noyaux des atomes et qui est
pourquoi est-ce qu'ils ont des orbites
et tous ces systèmes d'orbites avec des
liaisons cohérence comme ça toute la
chine tout ça ça s'explique par des
histoires de théorème de pythagore et de
géométrie euclidienne ce que je trouve
assez fou que j'espère que vous avez
aimé cet épisode donc là ça fait
plusieurs épisodes qu'on voit des trucs
très bizarre avec l'infini dans le
prochain épisode on va en voir cette
d'un coup
la vie sur ce que je redoutais ce qu'on
puisse infra ma première vidéo
si vous voulez en savoir plus sur les
applications des courbes de iwwert à
l'informatique qui utilise aussi
d'ailleurs l'année de police étaient
superbes vidéos
et puis si vous avez aimé cet épisode
penser à la ligue et à le commenter est
elle partagée pour ça vous abonner
épisode merci aux tipa awards on espère
que joueur